[Music]  it's been 10 years since the zombie  apocalypse and this dysfunctional family  very do you know what I would like I  don't give a [ __ ] what you might have  survived by using their whiskeys nothing  personal how could that not be personal  that's like my whole thing yeah you're  right it was personal on October 18 what  made you do it  and don't say descriptive can this be  just between us drugs cost money didn't  see that coming right you'll be the  first to die but I like your enthusiasm  you might die yeah thank you for your  sacrifice from the directly event  me too right oh yes  and mitosis dick Casablancas okay well I  think I would have made a damn fine  president think those cigars were left  over from the Clinton administration  Academy Award nominee  what are you Harrelson let's kick some  dick on the award nominee Jesse  Eisenberg right now right now Academy  Award nominee Abigail Breslin got any  award winner Emma Stone that sings very  2009  [Music]